那接下来我们就进入今天的第一个部分我们现在把时间交给我们的讲师龙毅好的OK 大家能看到我的屏幕吗可以 没问题OK 大家好 我是龙毅然后今天给大家带来的这个分享的主题是国际化的漫谈
首先就是漫谈是因为国际化这个topic比较大然后其实很难以待半个小时内给大家把每一个细节点都讲得很好所以更多的话本次的分享会是一个偏向科普和讨论性质的一些这种我自己的包括我自己
做这个国际化研发以来的一些这个感悟之类的如果大家有一些更深入的想探讨的问题到时候可以去里面咱们细聊然后首先这个简单的介绍就是呃呃之前是在这个滴滴做国际化呃个人爱好写了很多但是归咎起来呃就三个一个喜爱玩另外一个呢呃这个喜欢去解决一些问题第三个就是喜欢炒股对这个程序人爱炒股的人还挺多的
对我也是然后呢这次呢这个漫谈国际化呢我们主要其实就讲三个topic国际化是什么国际化要做什么国际化研发要怎么才能做得更好其实主要的话就是会讲到就是国际化要做什么这个部分那么首先介绍一下国际化是什么国际化呢我们经常说呢其实就是四个字母啊g i l t这四个字母代表什么意思呢它其实就是一个
非常简单的四个单词G11n,i18n,l10n和t9n那么他们分别代表什么意思呢G11n代表就是11代表到中间有多少个字母G11n就是globalization全球化i18n呢就是国际化l10n呢就是本地化然后t9n就是翻译那么他们
四个彼此之间的关系是什么样的呢他们更多的情况他们并不是完全相等的如果按照一个关系来概述的话呢你可以理解为就像下面的这个描述一样的就是首先全球化它是包含国际化跟本地化的而本地化呢它其实某种程度上它也包含这个翻译那只是它的大致的一个关系
那我举一个例子假如你原本做中国市场然后你现在要拓展到海外那么像全球的用户来介绍你的产品需要几步呢就像大象关到冰箱需要几步一样第一步打开冰箱门第二步把大象塞进去第三步关上冰箱门
那么你做出海的产品呢实际上也就三步第一步做国际化的改造第二步做本地化的支持第三步投放产品如果我们抽象起来就这么简单当然哈如果只有这么简单那就不用单独开个话题来聊了我们举一个简单的例子以麦当劳为例就是麦当劳的全球化国际化和本地化分别代表什么
首先全球化就表示说麦当劳其实在全球的100多个国家经营了三万多个餐厅然后全球大家都认可麦当劳它是一个什么样的品牌对吧那么国际化是什么意思呢就是麦当劳它本身是从美国发源它从美国向到其他市场推广的时候然后呢它需要将它的产品和它的服务具备有弹性也就是适应性以便于它可以更容易的
去进入其他国家的市场而本地话是什么就像麦当劳一样在中国他叫麦当劳对吧然后呢在美国呢他肯定不会写中文的三个字麦当劳对吧同时譬如以色列他他可能会提供一些譬如犹太教的食物和饮料同时呢他的休假的日期也不一样印度呢他甚至会有一些无肉的餐厅对吧麦当劳提供无肉的餐品给印度的这个用户而在
无论他在各个国家跟地区保持什么样的一种适应的情况他本身他还是卖当劳他依然保持了他全球的品牌形象但是他定制化的去为各地市场做了一些定制的产品与服务这就是大致来说全球化国际化和本地化的区别和概念所以本质上来说
我们说的国际化其实应该说的是全球化那么国际化首先如果我们要改造把我们的产品服务改造成更适合出海的东西那我要怎么来做呢第一步就是国际化的改造它就是为了去向全球市场推广而做的一个规划和准备在这个过程中它是不带有任何本地化的所谓的假设性的东西譬如说中国
那中国有什么 比如说中国是东巴区 中国用人民币对吧 然后呢 语言用中文 对吧用汉语用简体中文 这都是属于在中国市场本地化的一些东西如果你要做 那么你使员第一点 你要把你所有本地化的东西摘掉
让它变成一个全球化的框框所以如果你只做了国际化改造你是并不可以去向海外投放的你要投放去某个市场那你就同时还要做本地化的适配那么在这个维度上有三点第一点就是语言跟文字第二个标准与规定第三个文化和隐私语言和文字我们又会分为三块就看左上角的这个
小图就是他包括呢语言文字地区然后书写顺序以及呢这个文法那首先看左下角然后语言文字地区他们并不是完全一样的概念比如说地区和中国对吧中国大陆那么呃他用语言跟文字是什么汉字简体中文对吧然后他的local是这个zhcn如果是美国呢他可能用的拉丁字我用的是美诗英语
对吧用的enos如果是加拿大的话呢那么他加拿大的法语区加拿大有英语区也有法语区对吧加拿大的法语区用的是什么呢他用的是拉丁字母是加拿大的法语对吧他的local可能是这个frca这就是语言文字和地区的区别然后呢数学顺序呢就可以看到这个右边这一边的这个这个LTR跟RTL就什么是LTR就是
RTL主要就是用在更多情况下用在中东地区它主要是针对语言的有六种语言是需要使用RTL的方式什么叫RTL就像图片一样的首先第一它是从右往左读它的顺序是从右开始然后它的左箭头向左表示前向右表示后然后同时只有这六种语言需要进行RTL的适配
然后这六种语言覆盖的国家基本上就是在北非地区中东地区比如说西伯来语就是以色列阿拉伯语就是你懂的这个中东地区阿波国家或者是北非的这些国家然后同时这个波斯语主要是伊朗这样的这个基本上也在中东地区然后我们说文法这个文法就是一个比较
比较大的一个概念就是什么叫文法呢就是语言的一些相关的特性主要分为四个维度就是譬如说你要向国外去投放你的产品第一点你就要翻译嘛对吧然后语言它就会有很多的维度譬如说语言有什么有阴阳性什么叫阴阳性就是中文没有阴阳性你譬如说德语俄语俄罗斯语
对吧 它有三个性就是它有阴性 阳性和中性然后呢 譬如还有两个性的像法语 瑞典语对吧法语是阴性跟阳性 瑞典语是通性跟中性然后同时呢 他们还有单复书就像我们经常用的对吧在这个阴语后面这个复书可能加s或者加es之类的然后你像这个阴阳性呢
举个很简单的例子像俄语里面我这个图上已经写了动词的过去是随着名词性的变化而变化
也就是说你看这个三句话阳信音信跟中信俄语我不会读啊所以我没办法给你解释我是在网上找的一个例子就说同样在中国里面表示类似的意思比如杂志放在桌上书放在桌上信放在桌上它都是某一个东西放在了桌上曾经放在桌上但是因为杂志书和信的不同就带来了它整个文字上的不同你们可以看它第二个单词第二个单词他们每一个是不一样的
阳性一性和中性所以你如果希望你的这个产品能够贴合对方的市场那首先对吧你也得懂这些东西并且你能够支持这样的事情那么大小写旗意呢我就举了一个段子就是这个做iOS同学叫iOS对吧就是iOSER对吧如果你把这个大小写写错了你把i写成l这个写成然后写成大写os写成小写那看起来就像loser对吧
然后那大小写也同样的这个China也是样的小写的China是辞去大写的是这个中国那么标点符号呢就举个例子像我举了一个例子英语阿拉伯语和汉语的斗号他们是三种不同的字符他们在unicode马上是完全不一样的他们看起来相似但是完全不一样
对吧然后呢这也是他们之间的斗号同时像西班牙语有特点就是他如果是表达疑问剧或者他表达感叹剧他要把标点符号放在前面他倒过来的他是一个倒的问号和一个倒的感叹号而这样的东西都是人家在生活中息息相关的你不可能因为说我是中国人我做一个这样的产品那你就要去支持他你就要去适配他你就要让你的产品看起来更像本地人做的产品对吧
OK,那怎么来支持跟改造呢?首先第一点,就我们刚刚提到的local也就是刚刚说的,譬如ZHCENUS,那么它就local。local支持首先就是你的前后端,如果你要做改造,首先你要在前后端肯定要增加一个存储的自断去存储这个local。同时你要针对特定local做RTL的支持,因为它并不是说在你的定位是什么样,是什么样。
而是它是跟着你的语言变化的如果你使用阿拉伯语那你的界面就应该变成Local的样子同时呢你要根据这个Local做一些区分跟下发对吧然后呢这个提供对应的处理如果是多个国家使用同一个语言当然你也可以内部去处理它比如它可以附用某一个Local那么刚刚我们提到的文法类的问题
文法内的问题是什么呢就是刚刚说的什么阴性阳性啊什么复数啊就一天都很头疼的东西怎么解决呢也并不是没有解法啊因为你想全球这么多国家做这个做这个全球的产品他们肯定有一样的问题
ls里面呢,他就用了这个diskdict文件来适配它,它是一个插描的形式,安卓也可以用getquattitiesdreams来处理。存储呢,一定要用unicode的编码,就是你的数据会有unicode的编码。这个是非常非常重要的,因为很多字符,全世界很多语言,它有可能
在有些编码上并没有相关的支持如果你使用的编码是错误的那么可能会出现一些意想不到的问题那么从产品上来说呢就是有些地方是需要关注的譬如说排序对吧你如果是英文像我右边的这样图如果你是英文你可能是A排序
对吧然后如果你是中文你可能是拼音排序那么这个就可能要根据你的语言的相关而定然后同时有个小坑小坑是什么呢就是在ls里面呢这个多语言如果一个文件你的字符太多大于四万个字符有可能解析不出来这个时候呢就会建议要多拆分几个这个语言文件
当然刚刚提到的文法规则只是非常简单的一些例子如果大家关心可以去看一下CLDR你就去搜CLDR就好了然后同时第二个就是给你的设备和界面留足足够的支持怎么来做呢就可以看到右边的图我就以右边图为例这是我新鲜节的图 昨天晚上节的
就是呢我就以二冷摩那个支付宝为例就是呢我结了一个中文的和一个英文的你会发现呢如果我仅仅像支付宝这个排版是非常密的中文我同时排五个没有任何问题但是如果你英文排五个可能已经就点点点点点点了这个就其实对用户来人就不是特别友善这个然后呢像左边呢他就是一个这个国外的一个外卖的软件那么你看他就是
虽然它也是排布的但是它排布没有这么密它可能放了四个有一些软件可能就譬如一排放了三个这其实就是如果我要做国际化那我要考虑到像这样比较紧密的排布可能并不适用于国际化产品然后呢那这种情况下呢就第一个譬如说你要给文字留出足够的空间你可以根据字体制服的宽度来计算我大概这个label需要放多大的空间以避免去显示点点点点点点
第二个就是你搜的图片不要带文字第三个如果你有图文混牌的情况那一定要考虑到这个图文混牌的情况因为有些字体或者有些语言图文混牌非常的好看但有些语言有些字体看起来就会非常的别扭就像苹果最新出的这个环绕式的中文的一个表盘界面就有一点奇怪
对吧当然英文就会非常好看然后呢包括呢这个rtl里面呢就是你要考虑文字的顺序和布局如果有方向性的图片也需要单独的处理对然后建议最好是为你的大中小评出一个语言的适配然后呢关于这个时间呢就我们讲到第二part这个规定与标准那么首先我们讲时间就是什么时间时间日曆日期时间时去令时之都算时间类然后时间类呢
很多情况下譬如说日利就是当然我说的这些并不代表你的产品全部都要用上你有可能会选择一些用但日利呢大部分全世界大部分国家用功利还有农历 伊斯兰利日本日利等譬如日本日利他用这个什么昭和呀等等的一些这个天皇的年号来
來紀念然後日期的格式也是這樣的你譬如說他有這個年月日有日月年我右邊的右邊的圖裡面呢你也看到我舉了一些例子就是就是譬如說芬蘭語他的這個時間格式一般怎麼寫他是這個這個這個這個天這個
天月年而且他中间分割服是点有些是分割服杠学分割服斜杠等等这个都不完全一样时间也是一样的有些用冒号有些用点有些用空格都不一样然后东夏令时呢就是每个国家他都有完全不一样的规则甚至在美国他的这个州的时间也不一样然后时趋也是一样就是大部分的时趋是整数但是有很少不一样的是半个小时的星期呢就是
看这个一周的第一天的不同然后如何来改造呢第一点就是存储一定要用这个UTC时间同时呢存储类型呢一定要注意就是呢这个应该要使用这个正确的格式日期的这个格式呢要用国际标准因为我们有国际标准ISO8601你就去搜这个就好了然后呢这个如果有一个备注如果你
数据库你存了北京的时间你没有把它变成标准时间那就不要变了如果你已经击中难返你就不要强行去变它了因为这还影响你国内的用户不是吗你可以把它统一都用北京时间来存你只要保持一致性就好然后数值内数值内的话呢这个地方呢就是我们经常说的就什么数值内就是这个
这个签很大的一个数然后小数点等等的大部分的国家呢他的这个小数点就是有两种情况一个是点一个是斗号然后呢还有一种情况呢大部分的国家呢千卫福就是一万的对吧这个中间有个千卫福你想美国啊中国啊我们可能都会用这个斗号但有些国家用空格有些国家用点然后这个图上呢就是一些展示哪些国家用斗号哪些国家用这个
点来作为小数点的一些地方同时呢并不是所有地区都用阿拉伯数字譬如阿拉伯地区它就有存这个阿拉伯语的车牌这是一个车牌上面没有任何阿拉伯数字另外by the way这个阿拉伯数字是印度人印度人发明的
这个然后呢说到货币 货币呢其实就是有很多很多维度就是譬如说当然他有统一的标准然后呢有ISO标准定义上CNY USD这个都属于这个货币的单位然后呢这个人民币的货币人民币的单位并不是RMB啊这个大家一定要记住是CNY好同时他会有些前罪同时在后也会有后罪譬如人民币的原
日元的EM等等但是一定要记住前綴它可能有很多冲突的模式譬如说人民币跟日元它都用类似洋的符号对吧然后港币和美金它都用Dollar的符号同时缩写也会不一样英语是EM1K日语或者那个汉语用1万1亿之类的然后怎么来改造呢货币是非常非常重要的一个东西然后
所以首先第一个货币一定是有标准的也是ICU标准ICU不是那个进996ICU的那个ICU我写了一个全称然后大家可以去搜一个ICU标准然后不要看见ICU就想到要进ICU然后大部分的所以我们如果要设置所有的S8的规范那么一定要注意Ulico的支付机
用Utf8编码用ICO的国家化组建同时你的存储里面MySQL如果要用MySQL的话不要用Utf8存储因为Utf8并不完全兼容Utf8编码这又是一个冷笑话用Utf8MB4更合适存储一定要用64位的大致富存储因为我举右边这个例子你看货币
有多长对吧所以你如果存储的太小它就存不了同时存储一定要带货币类型比如说你刚刚举了例子这个议员在美国是议员在哥伦比亚这个是1000元对吧然后类似这样的一些小的点所以一定要记住
然后呢有些其他的规定这个就就快速的说了电话地址姓名和其他规定其他规定By the way说一下就是比如像巴西啊他他要求这个这个AP他要构建无障碍的社会所以如果你的app去了巴西有可能会被呃游戏有比较重要的话可能是要强制支持这个残障人士使用的尤其是市障人士的这个这个使用
文化和禁忌这是一个很多的段子啊就可以说段子的时候到了就是实际上第一个政治上的禁忌就是这个国家跟地区了我们都懂对吧然后呢包括地图的显示这个是非常敏感的所以做的时候一定要非常的注意因为每个国家的定义并不仅仅是就我们国家才有这种纠纷全世界很多国家都有同时呢宗教对吧这个这个Mary Christmas她是个宗教性的节日并不是全世界并不是所有地方都过圣诞节
但他们都放假所以这个可以用这个happy holiday然后文化隐喻譬如说我们叫666666在中文是很牛的意思但是在外国是邪恶的意思对吧譬如说这个这个这个这个江东这个这个这个在国外一般用于无民室譬如小民譬如说一个无人任领的尸体他可能就给他取名叫江东所以如果有个人叫这个名人这个就会有点像我叫小民
一样的道理然后对吧耐克傻逼对吧这个在中文是这个意思但是人家并不是人家是一个滑板鞋的意思对吧然后知评和手势也是一样的像ok在巴西表示一个不文明在美国甚至会有种族歧视的嫌疑就是我举了一个例子就是他会认为是叫白人力量白人至上所以他会有种族歧视的嫌疑像这样的一些东西都特别需要注意
然後我們說一下合規的一些點就是合規的話呢就是有三個事實就是全球85%的國家跟地區是對隱私立法而合規的本質是面向監管的風險一定存在且無可避免你無論做成什麼樣都有可能中招對但是呢
你也不能摆烂说我不做对吧因为如果不做又可能会归零然后呢合规呢我就举了一个非常简单的一个框架大家就看了就行了就是一般来讲就是就是极为多产品测数据测和流程测的合规然后呢产品测一般譬如我要满足知情权隐私要声明被遗忘权用户要可以注销同时注销之后数据要可以删除携带权什么就是用户如果说我要下载我的数据是可以下载的辩根权隐私要有开关
然后数据特的合规那就简单就数据的几个这个生命周期采集传输存储使用和销毁对吧然后流程策呢那就很简单就是我出了问题要响应要处置甚至紧急要上报对吧内部公司内部要有信息安全的这个管理然后我画了几个这个符号儿童隐私最小画原则数据跨境和用物画像是这其中里面非常重要的级点
然后我举了几个case就是数就是数据都是一说到何归就是罚款然后呢基本上所有的case都是罚款然后数据删除比如说这个google对吧被罚了十几万因为他没有删除或者说德国对吧被罚了一千多万儿童隐私呢就是可能是按人头罚一个人多少钱那你想你的这个
公司承不承受的起这样的罚款欧盟的GDP甚至说他会要求要给你全球营养的4%作为罚款反正所有的事情都是罚款只要你一涉及到合规一定是花钱的对吧这个一定一旦被抓就是就是花钱用户画像呢就Facebook比如收集用户的隐私宗教敏感讯息也被罚款等等非常非常多甚至有坐牢的风险比如说警方要你提供数据你不提供你就可能会被抓
那什么算敏感数据比如用户的相关的这个我就快的讲了这个都是基本上相通的位置精确的位置也是隐私的然后用户的隐身比如兴趣象这个对吧你喜欢男的还是喜欢女的这可能也是敏感的数据然后呢生效的这个GDPR简单的讲这个我就不读了我就简单的说就是呢18年开始执行
而且无论你的地方就是收集什么东西只要你向欧盟的用户提供你的商品你就需要遵守这个条例他的罚款是以营业额的4%罚款所以非常的高然后呢儿童隐私呢就是基本上就是欧盟你可以这么理解所有的合规相关的非常严格的几个国家中国美国和欧盟就是就是大概这一片其他地方可能管的没有那么严格但是你一旦在这几个都会非常严格
然后儿童隐私什么呢就两点一点就是用的话要家长授权第二个有些产品可能说那我就禁止你使用那样也可以但是如果你不禁止那就有问题然后说一个大家可能最近不太了解大家有时候用网站的时候会发现有就是这个右边的这个提示叫做Cookie就是这个要使用Cookie它有个提示为什么呢要提示呢因为
这个呢如果做的不好呢也是要罚款的对吧只要还是那句话只要设计合规都要罚款然后呢Cookie就是我的那个前端网页上的Cookie对吧你要使用之前你一定要这个获取用户的同意我就列了几个罚款记录都是以这个多少万欧元这个起跳的对然后呢而且都是这种非常大的这个公司
所以然后呢我们说一下数据跨境数据跨境这个概念比较大但实际上能做的事情其实其实就是这一些什么叫数什么叫数据跨境就是你的数据从这个比如说你在中国的数据这个传输到了国外或者你在国外的数据传输到了另一个国家
你在美国的数据传到了墨西哥等等等等那这就要跨境跨境的话呢其实很多国家是不太被允许的就是就是把你的这个用户的信息不管你是什么原因有可能是数据同步啊有可能是各种没有想到的一些小的细节但是他都会涉及到数据跨境那么这个情况呢一般就是几种方案一个监控对吧把你的这个介入层的专线监控起来然后另外一个呢前端客户端呢就做扫描做拦截做分析
然后有几个小的地方有坑的地方譬如说第三方SDK他也可能会发一些数据对吧然后跨境的CDN譬如说你用CDN做了加速但是你实际上你可能你这个App用的CDN是别的国家的然后你这个可能你传输了一些东西然后你传输了一些信息虽然可能是图片但这个图片可能是敏感的一些图片的话那也可能会导致一些比较大的问题
然后呢最后一点就是这个这个topic太大了所以半个小时其实讲的非常的快没有办法一点点的细讲我只能给大家一些小的建议这就是ppt的最后一页了就如何能做得更好做国际化也好做什么也好
就是降低认知成本是非常重要的一个事情就不用沟通就能达到目的的方式是最好的沟通方式如果一个人他不需要学国际化就能把国际化支持好这就是国际化研发应该要努力的方向对吧然后技术原则是什么呢走一套同一套配置独立一个团队维护以及所有的介入方无需了解即可搞定然后代码层面上呢其实就是四大块S8N就刚才说的什么货币啊符号啊时趋翻译对吧合规和机房
然后同时呢这个需要唯一注意的一点呢就在测试的维度上呢因为随着国家的越来越多你如果你的这个分支条件非常多的话对测试来讲就是一个非常可怕的噩梦籍的一个事情那么这个时候对国际化研发的挑战来讲如果你能在测试维度上去帮助到呃这个更好更快的能够能够测好一个东西的话那实际上也会能够去帮助国际化做得更好
好了然后我的分享就是这一些然后谢谢大家然后因为今天讲的比较快比较简略如果有任何的问题也欢迎大家随时的提问谢谢OK你们的主持人上线了非常感谢龙毅精彩的分享我说实话我觉得确实因为时间受限但是能感觉出来就是整个PPT还是非常精华
我觉得因为其实它是一个很大的话题但是我觉得就是容易能在这么短的时间内把这个部分讲这么好确实是非常非常难的然后当然我觉得挺有意思的就是刚才就是大家在直播间还说说这个分享内容还特别有趣感觉就是像听了个段子然后就把知识给学了ok稍等我关一下我的屏幕哎 容易你是不是之前也没有很少在对外做一些分享
嗯对是的是的因为我这个我感觉是不是你第一次对外面做分享啊那也不是那也不是之前在那个价格式峰会有讲过一次啊对然后那也是我觉得太荣幸了太荣幸了我觉得几年几年对可以可以确实能邀请到你是真的很荣幸OK好的那我们再次感谢农一的精彩分享啊那